thank you in case you don't already know
you will be absolutely delighted when
you learn what my function is this
evening I'm as proud as I can be of what
I've been asked or indeed allowed to do
it will be my happy privilege and honor
to present an actor and what an actor
who is a peer among his peers because
you see he is truly a peer and of course
I referred to Laurence Olivier because
that's how because you see that's how he
prefers I refer to him when he appears
those of us who had the joy of knowing
him since he first came to Hollywood
warmly and fondly yet respectfully of
course call him Larry no man has graced
his profession better than Larry Olivier
has graced ours he represents the
ultimate in acting is the actors most
admired actor his extraordinary talents
have embraced an astonishing variety of
roles from Shakespearean to modern day
men it's a remarkable achievement
unmatched in range or stature he has won
11 nominations think of that plus a
special Oscar for his Henry the fifth
and an Oscar as Best Actor for Hamlet
and tonight he received a tribute from
the Academy and the entire industry for
all his work among those who have
previously received this particular
honor have been Greta Garbo Mary
Pickford Fred Astaire Charlie Chaplin
Walt Disney and a named modesty forbids
that I should otherwise like to proudly
mentions
oh dear friends am I supposed to speak
after that carry my dear old friend for
many years from the earliest years of
either of us working in this country
thank you for that beautiful citation
and the trouble you have taken to make
it and for all the warm generosities in
it mr. president and governors of the
Academy committee members fellows my
very noble and approved good masters my
colleagues my friends my fellow students
in the great wealth the great firmament
of your nations generosity this
particular choice may perhaps be found
by future generations as a trifle
eccentric but the mere fact of it the
prodigal pure human kindness solid must
be seen as a beautiful star in that
firmament which shines upon me at this
moment
dazzling me a little but filling me with
warmth and the extraordinary elation the
euphoria that happens to so many of us
at the first breath of the majestic glow
of a new tomorrow from the top
or this moment in the solace in the
kindly emotion that is charging my soul
and my heart at this moment I thank you
for this great gift which lends me such
a very splendid part in this your
glorious occasion thank
you